vous êtes sur France 24 et vous avez
raison bienvenue dans votre journal de
l'Afrique à la une ce soir des
manifestations réprimées dans la
violence ou Tchad une semaine après le
bilan revu à la hausse par l'opposition
qui annonce plus d'une centaine de morts
le Président de la Transition évoque une
insurrection minutieusement préparée
avec le soutien des puissants étrangères
nous ferons le point avec son directeur
de cabinet adjoint de passage à Paris
monsieur Abdel Nasser
clôture officielle du dépôt des
candidatures pour les législatives du 17
décembre en Tunisie puis d'un millier de
candidatures ont été déposés pour à
peine 200 femmes la nouvelle loi
électorale est fortement critiquée elle
privilégie les individus individus au
détriment des partis politiques
reportages à suivre
et si je vous dis Maracana vous me
répondez célèbre au stade au Brésil je
vous dirai que c'est aussi une sorte de
football qui se joue à 6 et qui est très
populaire en Côte d'Ivoire là-bas
certains lui souhaitent même un destin
Olympia
ce furent les violons les manifestations
les plus violentes du Tchad au moins 50
morts selon le gouvernement 127 selon
l'opposition une semaine après ce drame
nous recevons Abdel Nasser guerbora
directeur du cabinet civil adjoint au
président de la transitions tchadiennes
merci Monsieur garbois d'être avec nous
alors votre président donc a déclaré ce
lundi que les manifestations de jeudi
dernier étaient une insurrection
minutieusement préparée je cite avec le
soutien des puissants étrangères
pourriez-vous nous dire précisément à
quoi ou à qui fait-il référence merci je
pense que le chef de l'État il détient
des informations très sérieuses sur tout
ce qui tourne autour
de manifestations au Tchad
lorsqu'il y avait eu l'autorisation
d'une manifestation au mois de mai
dernier
nous avons vu les puissances étrangères
qui ont été mises en avant par lesquels
c'était visible sur les télévisions sur
les images sur
sa tournait en boucle les images les
drapeaux qui ont été ici au Tchad donc
je crois que c'est ça c'est un secret de
polichinelle et le Tchad se trouve dans
une sorte de lutte de puissance
qui sont instrument qui tirent chacune
de son côté
le drap et donc la géopolitique
actuellement mondiale à l'un de ces
terrains en Afrique et le Tchad qui est
un allié de l'Occident depuis le début
le Tchad qui est en opération sur tous
les théâtres de lutte contre les
terrorisme que ce soit dans le Sahel ou
au lac Tchad et vraiment au devant de la
scène et c'est tout à fait naturel et
tout à fait normal je pense que de
puissance étrangères essayer de vouloir
contrôler alors vous nous dites pas
précisément quelle puissance étrangère
parce que secrets de polichinelle nous
on voit pas à qui vous faites référence
ou à quoi pourtant l'opposition a appelé
à manifester contre la décision de
prolonger et c'est de là que c'est parti
de deux ans l'après période de
transition avant les élections écoutez
c'est à dire que ça c'est une lecture
simpliste de des événements il faudrait
d'abord voir la chronologie des choses
mais avant de m'engager dans cette
dans cette histoire je voudrais d'abord
rendre un hommage et présenter vraiment
mes regrets aux parents des victimes
tchadiennes de cette de cette
insurrection du 20 mars qui a été
minutieusement préparée du 20 octobre
excuse-moi qui a été minutieusement
préparé et
c'était déclenché par un poste sur
Facebook à minuit des transformateurs où
ils ont fait un dièse air c'est sur leur
page si vous partez aujourd'hui ils ont
déclaré
#r code GSR enclenché un truc comme ça
et à partir de ce moment de horde de de
de de personnes déjantées et autres qui
ont pris la ville en brûlant de pneus en
s'attaquant à des personnes ainsi de
suite et et
manifestants n'ont pas été tués par des
policiers pendant cette manifestation
écoutez pour l'instant il y a une
enquête qui est ouverte pour savoir qui
a fait quoi mais il faudrait d'abord se
rendre compte de ce qui s'était passé
avant les manifestations les gens
sortent les policiers les dispersent
avec de gaz lacrymogènes ça a été
toujours le cas or cette fois-ci
qu'est-ce qui s'était passé à partir de
minuit des personnes si vous voyez même
les images avec des des des des objets
contendants et autres en main sont
sortis dans la rue et ne sont pas sortis
uniquement pour manifester mais ils sont
sortis pour affronter ils sont sortis
dans une posture de offensive et
qu'est-ce qui s'était passé très tôt le
matin ils se sont attaqués à des maisons
de personnes privées notamment le
ministre d'État par exemple lors que
Médard sa maison était attaquée très tôt
le matin
les commissariats ont été attaqués très
tôt le matin et dès lors que les
commissariats ont été attaqués dès lors
que le policier sont morts
naturellement leurs frères d'armes qui
étaient sur le terrain ont été mis le
dos au mur et je crois que face à cet
événement qui n'a pas été du tout prévu
par eux ils ont été obligés de réagir ça
c'est la première des choses la seconde
chose il y a des caméras de surveillance
qui ont vu des personnes non contrôlées
des personnes non identifiées avec des
voitures civiles qui tiraient à bas réel
sur des manifestants donc tous ces
éléments réunis nous amènent à dire que
c'est une insurrection qui est
minutieusement préparée merci Monsieur
garbois on note que évidemment vous ne
reconnaissez pas finalement et vous
n'avez pas répondu sur la question
évidemment des puissances étrangères que
votre président a déclaré
sur dès lundi merci beaucoup vous étiez
vous êtes sur notre plateau et
directement adjoint du cabinet du
président de la transition du Tchad
merci beaucoup monsieur
on connaît à présent le nombre de
candidats pour les prochaines les
islatives en Tunisie du 17 décembre plus
d'un millier de candidatures ont été
déposés la nouvelle loi électorale qui
privilégie les individus au détriment
des partis politiques et vivement
critiqués par l'opposition un reportage
de lilia Blaise et de mbtili
dans ce bureau de l'instance supérieure
en charge des élections Tarek Megri
candidat à Tunis dépose pour la première
fois sa candidature
c'est la première fois que je fais ça
ce chroniqueur radio n'a pas
d'expérience politique qui vient du
quartier populaire de Mila et a souvent
été active dans le secteur associatif la
nouvelle loi électorale lui permet de se
présenter individuellement sans le
soutien d'un parti avec seulement les
parrainages de 400 signatures
la nouvelle loi électorale va permettre
un renouvellement de la classe politique
sans les partis politiques en même temps
nous avons aussi des difficultés car
justement en tant que candidat
individuel nous n'avons pas les mêmes
moyens pour faire campagne
dans son quartier où Tarek parle avec
des jeunes beaucoup ont du mal à
retrouver confiance dans la politique
la nouvelle loi électorale comporte des
failles et parrainages sont peu
contrôlés et même le président de la
République a admis qu'il y avait eu des
infractions Ramzi un soutien de Tarek a
accepté de nous en parler anonymement
ici il y a certains candidats qui en
profitent ils nous propose entre 3 et 6
euros pour qu'on leur donne notre
signature pour les parrainages je l'ai
vu de mes propres yeux puisqu'on me l'a
proposé directement
les associations d'observation des
élections critiqué la nouvelle loi
électorale car elle ne garantit pas la
parité au niveau des candidats
aujourd'hui avec le nouveau découpage
territorial pour les élections et la
tendance encore conservatrice à élire
des hommes surtout dans les régions
intérieures c'est difficile pour les
femmes de se présenter et de faire
campagne si la parité n'est pas imposée
dans la loi nous craignons qu'il n'y ait
pas beaucoup de femmes dans ce nouveau
Parlement seulement 215 femmes ont
déposé un dossier sur 1429 candidatures
en Guinée neuf opposant politique au
régime militaire de transition a été
inculpé et placé sous contrôle
judiciaire ce jeudi ils sont accusés
notamment de complicité de destruction
de bien public et privés lors d'une
manifestation contre la junte au pouvoir
à Conakry la manifestation a été
organisée par le fndc elle avait fait
cinq morts images ici signé Malik
Diakité
direction Arly au Niger les anciens
employés de cominaque filiales
nigérienne dorano exariva se plaignent
de leurs conditions de vie depuis la
fermeture de la mine d'akuta 7000
d'uranium a été fermée en mars 2021
environ 600 personnes ont perdu leur
emploi reportage à Arly darl Gira
plus d'un an et demi après la fermeture
de la mine d'uranium dakuta à Arlit la
cité au logelessentiel des employés de
la Cominac est très mal en point le qui
aura un pépin c'est ça le problème parce
que
commence à tomber
c'est ça la mère que vous voyez là-bas
les moustiques si tu n'as pas une
moustiquaire alors ton compte est bon
voilà maintenant que je suis passé déjà
ne font que
chercher des camions pour récupérer
l'eau reculer la chiotte tout tout tout
tout c'est ça les conséquences de la
personne qui a bouchée c'est la
communique c'est la communauté le moteur
elle a arrêté le moteur
malgré de longues négociations entre les
syndicats nigériens et la filiale locale
dorano exariva beaucoup d'anciens
employés sont insatisfaits des
indemnités de départ qu'ils ont touché
Yacouba a passé plus de 20 ans à
travailler dans la mine 20 millions de
francs Cfa je peux tenir encore deux ans
avec si ça dure au bout de deux ans si
je ne trouve pas d'emploi stable on fait
quoi des fois dès que tu payes une
maison ou alors une voiture et une moto
avec les frais que ça entraîne tu n'as
rapidement plus rien certains sont
obligés de revendre leur maison et leur
voiture 20 millions ce n'est rien la vie
est chère maintenant du côté de la
direction de la communale on exhorte les
exemployés à la patience des mesures
doivent être mises en place pour leur
permettre de devenir propriétaire
on a mené
des discussions avec le ministère de
bannissement
pour que les anciens travailleurs qui
désirent en tirer logement
y accéder
on a programmé ça pour faire décembre en
tenant compte de toute la douleur
administrative de toute vérité et tous
les vérifications qui vont se faire
plusieurs anciens mineurs reprochent au
groupe français Orano de ne pas avoir
mis en place un suivi médical suffisant
la direction de la communac elle s'en
défend 27 Nigériens ont pourtant porté
plainte en France contre X pour homicide
et blessures involontaire liées à
l’extraction de l'uranium
[Musique]
je vous emmène en Côte d'Ivoire à la
direction du Maracana ce n'est pas le
stade de football brésilien mais une
invention locale du football à 6 sans
gardien est tellement populaire que
certains rêvent d'enfer un sport
olympique Laurent versécher
un terrain de handball débute minuscule
et deux équipes de six joueurs de champs
qui s'affrontent bal aux pieds voici le
Maracana un sport au racine brésilienne
et inspiré du football mais 100% made in
Côte d'Ivoire Chenon il n'y a pas de
retraite depuis donc l'âge de 15 ans 10
ans 12 ans vous pouvez pratiquer le
Maracana tant que votre capacité
physique vous le permet jusqu'à 90 ans
né dans les années 70 sur les campus
d'Abidjan le Maracana dont le nom fait
écho au stade mythique de Rio de Janeiro
s'est invité sur les plages les terrains
vagues et les salles d'entraînement ce
foot allivoirienne est même devenu un
tremplin pour les jeunes qui espèrent
passer pro je m'entend plus tard il va
devenir comme Ronaldo
la petite taille débute et du terrain
font du Maracana un sport plus technique
mais aussi moins physique que le foot
l'occasion pour certains anciens joueurs
de haut niveau de prolonger leur
carrière
à la fois au stade et puis à l'Africa
les gens à l'international au Burkina
non c'est après ma carrière en 2010
voilà Monsieur le convertis au Maracana
l'équipe ivoirienne a récemment remporté
la maracan compétition africaine phare
un huitième sacre consécutif pour ses
joueurs qui rêvent d'un jour voir le
Maracana SEIC au rang de discipline
olympique
et c'est sur ces images que nous
refermons cette édition du journal
l'Afrique merci à tous ceux qui nous ont
suivi et en particulier ceux de Niamey à
Tunis en passant par Abidjan restez avec
nous car l'actualité continue sur France
[Musique]